hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome to another
winners on a wednesday this is where
every single week i interview one of my
success students who are
killing it in property this guy joseph
is financially independent
he's systemized a deal sourcing company
making around about 10
000 pounds per month he only started
about less less than a year ago now and
honestly his story is inspiring it's
gripping
you're gonna learn absolutely loads so
joseph welcome to the show samuel thank
you very much
for having me it's it's honestly
watching what you've done over the last
when did you very first get started in
this so really
um i came to the first crash course last
year in july
okay and about 18 months about that
about that
and i remember i was looking for
a way out from the business i had before
and
it was a little bit too good to be true
for me to
just find deals and then sell them to
the investors
so i came to for the first crash course
and then i went back home didn't think
about it much
and it was the second crash course where
i decided that i want to get some more
training
and actually see if that can really be
true
and that's how slowly i got where i am
today awesome
and and you've lost a lot of weight wow
well yeah you know
the other thing is pretty stressful work
so no no no no
gym every day i do you've become a
different person brother
it's really really i'm where i wanted to
be
yeah a year ago so yeah
well i am honestly and i know i saw you
at the crash course because you'd not
just been to two crash courses you just
keep coming back
like you were the virtual the very first
virtual crash course um
a few days ago which was was that good
was it good by the way it was really
good it was really good the energy was
great there was lots of people
yeah and we refreshed everything that
you usually say in the crash course so
it was really great but seeing you on
that call i was just like
we need to meet you need to come around
you need to share the story because you
were even at the crowd even at the crash
course
you know obviously it's a virtual crash
course but people are speaking and
chipping in
you know every time i'll i'll say
something about deal sourcing or i'll be
talking you know you'll have things to
chip in i'll see you in the background
on zoo you're doing deals
i just thought you know you've got
you've got so much to offer that's why
it'd be great to have you on the youtube
channel to share your story um and i
know it all started for you at the crash
course which is which is amazing
uh you went to do the deal selling
mastercard still finding the deal
um which was which was a three-day
program how was that for you
it was really great and you know i was
waiting for the part where
uh we will talk about deal sourcing i
remember it was the last
part of the of the course yeah and we
were
we had to run for the um to the plane
and you know on the deal finding
extravagance i was waiting for
that period where we talk about deal
sourcing because on that program you go
through every single strategy
yeah and the deal sourcing was the last
one
and i remember telling to my friend just
uh you know
give me five more minutes i have to
write down everything that alistair was
talking
about due sourcing and i went home with
uh with a plan
like when i saw how he sold a deal
yeah in few minutes um i
couldn't believe that that's possible
and i remember when that happened to me
the first time
when when i sent my deal email out and i
sold my first deal just by
getting a text message calling an
investor and walking through the deal
sent him an invoice and he paid it i
didn't know what to do
i was laying on the floor i was laughing
i was
crying i called all my friends i was
checking my account if this is true
yeah because i remember how much work i
had to put in
and how much effort to get the same
amount of
exchange yeah so i finally felt
validated you know
the thing i do actually there is value
in it and i can earn my living that way
so that's so good
it was so amazing because because prior
to thank you for saying that by the way
because
it shows the power of of the strategies
which we teach which is really really
good
but tell me what you were doing prior to
prophecy because i know things weren't
so good for you financially
um really so basically i had a cleaning
business a commercial cleaning business
and um it was running well we had about
20 staff about 120 clients
um but it took all my time
so a year ago before i came to crash
course i was looking for
some activity that i can do for a long
term i had two reasons
one is that i wanted to do something
that makes sense to do long term
with service companies like a cleaning
business fine you can have it systemize
you can you can have it all in place
but then you lose a key person in the
company or
something changes and all that work that
you have put in suddenly
can go can be gone so there was one
reason
and then the second reason was that i
wanted to have more time for myself
yeah um i wanted to you know travel
just have time for myself yeah and be
fit you know and
and things like that so as i say um
the reason why i became a deal sorcerer
it was because
i wanted to be a little bit more lazy
and just you know
enjoy life but also get the reward for
the work i do it's right though because
you can
if you package yourself a deal it might
take you a few days but it'll give you a
month's salary
yeah so you could take the rest of the
month off or you could sell a couple
more deals
that's right well you could do what
you've done which is really smart and
you could start building a team
which we'll get on to talk about and
then and then have it systemized
that's right that's right you know and
as i say um
i am a very reliable and responsible guy
so as i say
if i do that work responsibly and i
really put my effort in it
then finally i can get the reward i
think i deserve for all that work
and i think with deal sourcing i'm
getting that i'll tell you something
what i'll tell you why i think you're
winning a deal sourcing
i think you're winning because you
deliver to your investors i see so many
people on the facebook groups
posting i had a really good experience
with joseph you know
and i think that some people when you
learn how to make two three thousand
pounds
in a day you you could misuse that
and do it irresponsibly sell deals that
aren't great
use the ability to be able to sell which
of course we teach you
yeah and almost use it in an
irresponsible way but i think
if you do that all that's gonna happen
is three three months later
your investors are gonna be like yeah
actually i'm good thanks you might make
quick money but but you've been doing
this now for
a year or so and you've built up real
trust with investors
do you have many investors that buy from
you again and again repeat investors
exactly well that's that's the way um
investors who are
building their portfolios be it holiday
let's rent to essays or refurbishments
or bitewets
yeah they come back because we deliver
well we deliver what we promise we you
know we don't promise things that we
can't deliver
yeah and then um basically they trust us
as i say or
you know what i think is that investors
basically buy from a sorcerer because
they trust the sorcerer yeah
if i'm confident with my deal if i know
the in and outs about the property i
have done my numbers
i am confident then the investor also
feels confident to take it out
uh from yeah and you spent you know you
spent
a couple few thousand pounds on on
training with us
um were you apprehensive about doing
that did you were you
nervous about doing that or was it just
a complete no-brainer how did you feel
um
so i was very skeptical at first yeah
but
at the first crash course at the end you
know when you ask
the attendants if they want to do some
further training
um my my friend was telling me yeah
let's do it let's do it together
but i was reluctant i wasn't ready to
pay anything
for something that i don't believe is
real right because i don't really
believe that time that is
it's possible to do that but then when i
came for the second crash course
i already came with an idea that i want
to try and see and do some
extra training so that's when i sign up
for the dfe
yeah and come on it was amazing and
for that money because we were two uh
friends
uh i think we got fifty percent
discounts the second person yeah for the
second person
and it was uh three days it was
amazing with with so many people
networking
i remember we had party every evening so
yeah
for money come on it was great yeah i'm
really really really glad and also i
guess not just not just for the party
and the experience and the knowledge but
also
you made your money back quickly and now
you've gone on over the how much
how much how much has your business done
oh since
since the deal financial began so how
much is your so
um basically the start was very hard
right the first three almost four months
i haven't heard anything
yeah and i've been in a very difficult
position because i have decided that i'm
going to do it
um i have replaced myself in a cleaning
business which meant for me that i have
not anymore got that much income that i
was used to getting from that company
and then i remember i wanted to very
often give up
because it just didn't work i didn't
really i was trying to find deals
i was trying to do my best but i just
haven't made any money for the first
three and a half months
and then it slowly picked up and now
just now maybe
august september october is when
i can see the deals are really coming in
and going out from the company
yeah so it's at the moment
we are talking about eight to ten
thousand a month
that focus sourcing is achieving every
single month and it will be
continually going on even more from now
on
because i remember like when we spoke
because we you jumped on our zoom call
with me which is on
um which we put out as our initial
interview yes but it was
early days it was over zoom so we had to
do this properly
um and even then in april you know you
were you were killing it not to the
level you're at now
but you were stoked you were gassed you
know what it was
crazy really yeah that time and this is
all through this is all through 2020.
i mean for many people 2020 is a really
bad year for you that's not being the
case
no well i you know to be honest
this was one of my best years in in long
time
come on man i travel i look much better
than a year ago
i am financially okay i'm not stressed i
have a business that
is giving me enough to live and being
able to help my family
and and there is future in it that's the
thing that we can we can do it so much
better
yeah um so you know if we could have
this interview for five hours
i would happily talk about all the all
the things that i think i'm
i'm proud of in focus sourcing you know
where we born
in slovakia in slovakia and you've got a
son in
denmark so we separated with my ex-wife
in august and they live
in denmark here okay and one of the
reasons that you're doing this i know is
is for you son
that's right so tell me about it tell me
about that so
all right so the long term plan
is to have focus sourcing systemized
and worked out on a way that i don't
have to be here
all the time of course i'm not planning
to
never come back to the uk or to scotland
but i want to be more with my son
i want to be able to be with him not
just for a weekend
but maybe spend with him a week or two
weeks in a in a month
without having thinking of focus
sourcing
having some issues or problems so at the
moment um
we have most of the business already
systemized yeah
and i will be always present at focus
sourcing focus sourcing is me
and my team but i want to do it in a way
that i don't have to be physically
in scotland yeah so much you want to be
able to go to denmark to travel
to be with family and be with myself
okay wherever you want to be that's
right
and not have to be tied to the business
because deal sourcing is
like and i i say this it says very
active money
meaning it's not passive if you invest
money in property and it comes with
passive
deal sourcing you have to work really
hard for it but what you're trying to do
is you're trying to
replace yourself at least at least
you've done it already to a point but
replace yourself so that
it is passive or at least in part that's
right
and you know when when we're talking
about this basically
the one of the most important part of
the business is the network
so really when when we started to doing
well
it was when i realized that we need to
involve more people
into the company yeah so um network
through you know agents um a power team
and all the people that help us that's
where we get the leads
for the deals yeah and then um
we also work with people who care for
the investors after we sell the deals
so for example some sourcing companies
also do project managements
we don't we have a power team with a
project manager who then
takes over the investor and care for him
so our company can only focus on
finding the deals and uh because there
is the network
um yeah the team let me ask you some
questions that people might find
interesting about
about your business okay firstly where
do you source deals
do you stick to one particular patch do
you look everywhere and how do you how
do you determine that
all right so at the moment we source
properties all over scotland
because we work with another deal
sourcers you know compliance sourcers
who help us finding the deals
and of course we use any possible
platforms
right move and you know anything that's
on the market
yeah but really the best deals comes in
through agents who already had some
experience with us in the past
yeah yeah and that's not only for me
personally but also with
the sources that we cooperate so how do
you cooperate with the sources what's
yours what's your
so they find the deal they find the
property they secure it
and then they provide the details to us
yeah
what we have done we have three websites
one of the sites that we have
um it's allowing to deal sources to
upload the deal
um through a form a standard form so
every single deal has
you know a standard due diligence that
they have to go through
yeah and it's made on the way that if
you are a deal sourcer and
you haven't done your job properly like
you missed a few things
you cannot upload it you have to go
through the steps and so on
it's kind of like what we do in in in
the same way that we
you know we have the viewing inspection
sheets and things like that how we code
your source
and i think that you know what you're
doing is you're treating it like an
actual business because a lot of people
that do deal sourcing
they kind of act like self-employed
they're trying to just package and sell
one and two deals every so often
get a bit of money from it but you're
really you're really serious about this
thing
that's what you're showing in your in
your results that's right
it's it's a business and then you know
it's we help each other because
um there are active sources who are
really good
at sourcing properties they have a nose
maybe even a better nose for deals than
me
but then once there is a deal maybe they
have an issue to sell it
maybe they they don't have the right
investor who takes on that deal
and that's where um me and jacob come to
a picture because
we care for the investors we we check
what uh what is their ideal criteria
and then based on that we can offer them
the right deals
so your your strength more than anything
is the ability to go to find investors
and have a good network investors that
you can
care for look after and bring deals to
exactly like your usp
exactly talk to me because people ask me
all the time all right how do you find
investors like
where did you start finding these
investors how did it how did it happen
so you know all right to be honest i
feel like at focus sourcing we are like
a family
like many times happens that we find an
investor and then
he buy a deal from us and then he is
bringing another deal
from someone from his network to us and
you know we we constantly cooperate
so um i remember there are there are
some issues sometimes
um and i remember we had a little issue
at one
essay and i spoke with an agent and i
remember it was a very friendly
agreement
and we we made it on the best way for
everyone involved
and that's when we realized man we are a
team
it's not like you are an individual unit
as an investor
and then i am the sorcerer here we have
the official contract you just sign and
then
uh check the you know the clauses in the
co no no
we are like friends so i understand what
the investor needs he understands what
i'm doing
the agents is playing his part you know
the solicitor she is playing her part
and we we work as a team
yeah and there are sources we we refer
to each other as colleagues
because really we are we are having the
same purpose the same goal
yeah and then in the end everyone is
winning that makes sense you're
basically just all putting in the same
direction
transparent about what your goals are
open to work with
sources agents investors developers
whoever
and you're just pulling in the same
direction that's really really
interesting
where did your very first talk talk to
me about how you found your very first
investor and how it happened
all right you're falling around the
floor i want don't know what happened
all right so basically my first few
investors came from
uh your facebook group networking um
that's true well first i didn't really
ask
i was so happy there is an investor who
is buying my deal but then later on
um and we it was when it was last year
the end of last year but while we still
are cooperating we are still in contact
you know because things always go well
because if they go
bad we just caught you know we just
handle anything that's needed and in the
end it will go can i just say about the
group as well real quick because
people might think joseph got got deals
from the group and stuff
you have to work for that still because
i didn't
i didn't give you the deal sometimes
i'll give people the deal where i say
you're allowed to post on the group
as part of that you didn't have that no
i never thought well you did because i
remember
is you came onto the group 29 000
investors
you didn't sell because people come on
and they start trying to sell people
they get kicked off unless they get
permission before
what you did i remember was you came on
and people would ask questions
and you just started like asking how you
could help and bring in value
or you'd start when people would come on
and say i've just done you go on and you
say great job and
you just encourage people lift people up
build relationships add value
and then it kind of just became like
who's this joseph guy you kind of became
part of the furniture
and then as a result of that people
started messaging you indirectly
directly messaging you not on the group
saying like oh could you help me with
this deal or whatever
and then you started selling deals
because i was shocked when you sold me
i remember you saying to me like i've
just sold like three deals four dollars
i said
where are you finding the investors from
the group he's not
he's not spamming the group he's not
being salesy on the ground
and then i thought you know it just
shows the power of farming you're not
hunting
sowing seeds rather than trying to get
you know you were just
farming you were just building
relationships people sometimes going for
the kill a little bit they're going for
the juggling too quick
or they'll post on the group and say
anyone looking for any deals i've got
some stuff and
and it's just spamming no no no i never
done that and i remember
um one thing i learned from dfe is that
you don't post your deals anywhere else
just on your on your mailing list yeah
um and as i say the beginning was very
hard but
i think the most successful action that
uh we had in focus sourcing is that we
kept going and kept having deals and
kept finding deals
and sending them out on the mailing list
so those few investors who are there can
see that we are actually productive and
we are delivering those deals
even we haven't sold any yeah i have
been sending out deals for
for almost four months without selling
any
but it didn't matter because i knew if
we keep if we keep going with that
sooner or later there will be an
investor who appreciates our work and
will actually take us seriously you know
yeah what do you do when you find a deal
and then you try and sell it and it
doesn't sell um
so all right let me see we have
investors on on bespoke
basis who are looking for a specific
type of deals
yeah right so what we do if we have a
deal that doesn't match their criteria
we send them out on the mailing list if
it doesn't sell on the mailing list
then we still have all the contacts to
our investors on bespoke
with who we cooperated before and for
some reason you know
they are in the middle of a project or
at the moment they are not looking for a
deal
yeah and we we go into the network and
and see
who knows anyone who would be interested
in that kind of deal
so what what is tell me what what is
bespoke sourcing um bespoke sourcing is
when
um we we find out what's the investor's
idea about an ideal investment
so what is it that he is looking for is
it maybe maybe he is building his
buy to let portfolio maybe he he likes
to
you know recycle his money and do
refurbishments
or he likes to play with rent to assays
etc and then
we go out to the field and find the
specific deal for that investor
before you start looking do you take
some kind of payment up front
uh we do take a 500 deposit okay
so a small payment small payments 500
pounds to show they're serious
and then and then what's what he said
you say if i don't find something in x
amount of period then i'll give it back
or how does it work
so in the past i used to be very easy
on investors and i said you give me 500
pounds i will go out i will give you
unlimited amount of deals
you know and then you choose one you
like we don't do that anymore so at the
moment what we do is we take 500 pounds
as a deposit which is deductible from
the sourcing fee
we agree very specifically on the
criteria and we only take on an investor
with the criteria that we are actually
sure that we can deliver yeah
and then we offer him three deals so if
he doesn't take any of those three deals
we keep the deposit
yeah because you found the deals that
fit the criteria that fit the criteria
yeah
and you know i find that's the issue
with or at least there was the issue
with me because
at the very start i wasn't very
comfortable okay can i deliver this
criteria is it realistic or not so
i guess you might you might need some
experience and see
what's realistic in your area yeah at
your market what is it that you can
actually deliver or what is it you can't
yeah i had well in the year
we had two investors i refunded because
the criteria that we agreed on before
were just
so unrealistic that it was almost
impossible for us to find
or it would be you know taking very long
time
um before we get such a deal so we just
refunded them and said okay we can we
can take you on
but we have we have to reconsider what's
the ideal investment here you know so we
learned so much
how did you get from joseph at the first
crash course
skeptical unsure saying i'm not buying
any more training
to going back the second time actually
saying i'm open
my energy is good yeah i'm ready to buy
some further training
what happened um the reason i asked that
question
is because my job as a trainer someone
that's trying to empower people
bring financial freedom to as many
people as i can educate people wake
people up
to realize that you don't have to be
working in a job you don't have to be
the biggest problem i have is getting
the old joseph to the new
is that is that skeptical skepticism
like how how how how what is it that
happened
how do i or how do people how do they
change that
that light switch to turn from actually
close-minded to open minded to getting
the kind of results that you
you've been getting yeah well very good
question very good question uh
like really honestly i think i just
trusted you
like at the first crash course uh what i
have seen
the you know all that you gave us uh
during those two days
you know it couldn't it could not have
been fake no
none ever on the world can play it um
and fake it out so
i said okay let's let's give this a
little bit of trust and see
if it can work or not but of course i
was like you know 1700 pounds
that's not that much let's just see you
know
and i was i had a plan b you know
um if the course is just another like
um upselling or they will ask for more
money
i don't really mind i'm there with my
friend we have good time you know
and and so i haven't take it so
seriously but in the end
the course was amazing we really went
through every single strategy
yeah i remember it till today if you ask
me questions from dfe
i i remember what happened there because
we really went through every single
strategy
yeah and you remember we were talking or
you were talking about
um find your way what would you like to
do because when
people come to property investments
usually there is
so much interesting stuff to do that
they keep jumping around and do one two
three
and that's the thing i took from you
that's the one thing i took if you look
at focus sourcing who we are
we are deals so saying we are
sorcerers yeah we don't do uh all kind
of stuff around
we are the sorcerers yeah you want
anything else you can go to someone else
you come to us if you want to source a
property
yeah that's really interesting and
interesting it says the two things that
kind of
helps you with the the skepticism one is
i guess the the the the the value that
you got from the free stuff the crash
course was free or pound
youtubers and you thought well i've
received a lot of value already
and then the second thing is you're
saying look worst case
if i go on the advanced training and if
it's rubbish
it's not going to [ __ ] me no it
wasn't i don't know why people say
that those courses are so expensive it
wasn't expensive
for for all that we got no not at all
i mean the thing is that you're saying
that now
because you've made all the money back
and 10 times over and 10 times over
again
like so it's easy for you to say that
yeah but when someone's thinking
to invest that money and then not be
able to make it back
then it's expensive you know what samuel
i would say something else
um don't spend on training if you are
not willing to put in the work
try so when i came for the dfe
i wanted to get the knowledge yeah i was
i haven't really had issue that
um i wasn't trusting they will be good i
was expecting it to be good
because the crash cruise was was amazing
yeah so why would the
heavy not be right but i was willing
and ready to do the work yeah and
probably that's
that's where um people who are
complaining are coming from because they
have paid
anywhere with any trade uh you know
trainers they have paid for the course
and
they haven't applied they haven't put
the work in it yeah and they say it
doesn't work you know
of course it won't work yeah although
interestingly
you probably know this the people that
are actually complaining of the people
that never did the
people that maybe watched some youtube
videos maybe you went to the free crash
course and they were upset that there
was a further offer
but actually the va like that you went
to the tr
you wrote to the deal following cancer
the people in the room that they're
pretty happy
yeah it was pretty amazing pretty happy
it was pretty amazing um
it's the people that don't do it that
just speculate and think
that they come up with and you know
another funny thing um i remember
those times before the lockdown the
crash courses and the dfe
um i made few friends from
from from that network and
i know several people who started the
same time as me
are doing really well yeah and we are in
contact and they they done
amazing well they don't they are much
better than me to be honest yeah but you
know they done amazing things and i
remember sitting with that guy at the
crash course
and telling him you know why you're
thinking about this and oh you know
we were just discussing how how it's too
good to be true
yeah so that's great it shows that it
shows the people
that turn up and take the action
and then you've got to take the training
but you've also got to take the action
and that's what you've done you've
worked
you know really really hard so i admire
what you've done
what will be your final pieces of advice
to somebody watching this that's
thinking
you know how how do i get results in
property how do i get started what would
you say
um well i would say i would say to to
make a decision first
um and you know don't give up that
easily because if i can do it
if i can have a known sourcing company
which is actually
um making a good living for me a guy who
doesn't even speak
very well english you know um i think
anyone can do this
and keep being consistent i would say
don't
if something doesn't work or it's very
hard don't change it
just because it's hard um give it some
time
yeah and and it will work how would
one get in touch with you someone wants
to get in touch with the best of all
cool so i have a website yeah called
um deals from scotland core uk
deals from scotland dot co dot uk right
nice
deals from scotland
and um so that's the website and you're
very active on social media
that's right so you know people people
should definitely watch out for
you every you know you do so great as
well i have to say this every time you
do a deal with somebody
you take a picture or you do little
video and you can post it
and people don't like that people get
people get so upset with that i see
i see the haters you know they're like
they're like taking the mickey out of
you know you know the dangle the keys
yeah the the famous thing you do when
you're yeah
yeah you dangle the keys outside the
door you take a picture and you say you
know another one
you know or something um you know some
people really don't like that they they
get irked by it but
but i think that ultimately you can't
worry about you can't you can't worry
about that you've really put yourself
out there and i'm sure you've received
you know flak or envy or or whatever
doing that now you're going from
going from running who are you you're a
cleaner you're in a cleaning business
you know but i really admire you putting
yourself out there
in in the way that you have and uh it's
just been great working together over
the i know i know we've not been
physically working together but
virtually
online virtual crash courses deal
finding extravaganza you came to the uh
to the physical program and it's just
been such a it's been such a ride so
thank you so much thanks for your
support as well and um
you know you're always the guy you even
even through all the negativity i know i
had some bad flak and stuff you know you
you were the guy
who were the first to sort of like shout
sing the praises so i really appreciate
that
samuel thanks very much for the
opportunity and for all your support
and for everything that you are doing it
has been really great
and thanks again for having me here
appreciate you brother all right
so that's joseph he's an awesome guy
check him out on social media and you
know what if you've been inspired by
joseph's story what i would say is why
don't you stop stop being so skeptical
stop being on the fence get yourself
booked onto the property investors crash
course it all starts at the crash course
i can't wait to have you sat in my
living room as well when you're getting
the kind of crazy results that joseph's
getting
so i do this every single week every
single week i interview someone
one of my students is killing it in
property financially independent
i mean how many more people do i need to
interview before you go you know what
maybe i need to join in the action so
get registered if you want to watch the
whole playlist where i've got over 100
interviews like this
you can check it out right here also
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel
you can do that right here thank you so
much for watching i'll see you next time